yo what's the deal with your boy blast
make sure you check me out on the bullet
cav podcast
like cab show special guest is here
we're finally getting um are we
considering this your debut proj like i
know it's not your debut project but is
this like your
first like official album
yeah i will say that yeah we're getting
the first album ladies gentlemen it's
out right now
by the time you're watching this you'll
be able to go listen to the album
everywhere
highly anticipated project um
well [ __ ] man i mean i wasn't like what
i was gonna ask you why is the time now
but i mean we've been waiting for a
while so yeah yeah i guess why um why'd
it take so long
um i was on the road a lot last year
i was trying to find a balance of still
being creative
while being on tour you know that was a
challenge for sure so as soon as i got
back we pretty much wrapped it up
yeah you were i mean it's crazy to think
like how
how much that
ep no love lost did for your life yeah
bro changed my life drastically just a
small batch of records that really and
videos and and just aesthetics and just
the whole package and it just really
kind of just
i feel like it really kind of flipped
the whole coast on his head man yeah
cause when i was
like early on i was just putting out a
bunch of single single singles i was
like let me start my catalog just to
start it and that was no love lost and i
didn't know i'd be able to tour off that
just alone and not and not like just
tour but like
sell out [ __ ] shows man like what was
the uh was it new year's you did at nova
yep yep yeah new year's at nova look
crazy
yeah that's one of those shows like you
know there's like a gift and a curse
like doing radio in la because like the
homies will have shows
and i'll be like
if they're from here
i'll be like nah that i'm i'm not even
gonna bother trying to even
families uncles cousins homies are on
the list for that i'm just like i'm just
like where's when's the orange county
show
when's the observatory show my family a
pull-up in orange county more than they
pulled up in adelaide too
observatory's look like the low-key one
it's like yeah let me go to oc and kind
of get out the way of the la [ __ ] you
know exactly um but what's been going on
man obviously you've been working um i i
know you got a ton of visual shot
already yeah yeah we got a series
uh kind of like no love lost i did a
four-part video series so i'm keeping
that same trend with this one before you
go
um yeah i really want them to see it i
don't want to speak too much on it but
as far as the project it's really just
speaking on the transition i feel like
i'm facing as an executive you know i
got the eagle label so i'm signing other
artists right now
but i'm still trying to build my name
individually as well
yeah uh i talked to vic and uh on uh he
came up here for an interview and he had
kind of hinted that you guys had already
gotten your first artist
yeah shout out jay million from long
beach artist producer crazy he did a lot
of uh
a lot of joints on the six tape too
produce he produced him yeah he did like
five joints down there i want to say
yeah so he makes music is he a rapper
singer yeah
makes beats
he's kind of like you yeah
yeah better a better version a better
version of you that's saying a lot
can he make the artwork though can he
design the merch he'll get into it for
sure
he'll be making some more work um
yeah no that's dope i feel like you guys
have a great brand and i just feel like
the way you guys think about the music
industry
is very um
it's just forward thinking
and uh a lot of people
can learn a lot if they just pay
attention to what you guys are doing man
that's a compliment for sure we try to
be intentional we try to follow the
blueprint now you guys are writing your
own blueprint for real hard too you know
we can't really i mean i mean not for
none you guys really really if you
follow the blueprint you would have
probably
signed with atlantic or something and
then like you know
in five years been complaining on
instagram about your deal yeah that's
true we kind of went down you bet on
yourself bro yeah and it worked yeah
yeah i feel like the way because vic was
breaking down just the whole red bull
situation the way you guys went into
those meetings i was like that was a
good ass interview too i've seen that
yeah it was dope man
has he gotten you in any trouble with
the irs yet nah we're on top of that
real time for that for sure
uh
yo um
when it comes to your sound i feel like
you have your sound right
uh signature blast sound um is there any
uh evolving that did you get in any sort
of uncomfortable creative spaces on this
project where maybe you took a little
bit more risk when it comes to maybe
some of the tempos or some of the things
you you did yeah i think that's only
right especially you know when people
feel like they predict my sound or know
how i'm gonna come i'm gonna always go
left but i'm gonna still keep my roots
what people know me for but i'm gonna
always experiment try different [ __ ]
cause i'm a fan of
music before just being an artist i
wanna try different [ __ ] anyway i don't
wanna box myself in
what was it like um getting with zakari
because i think zakari's one of those
guys who's very um
he's like a you know i feel like he
doesn't really sound like anybody you
know he's very much
unique
super talented [ __ ] when i heard him on
kendrick's love i legit thought like i
thought it was a lady on there
shout out to card but nah that's
speaking to
one of them orthodox and other
unorthodox approaches that i'm talking
about like just linking up with artists
like that somebody would never expect me
to do a song with zakari and that [ __ ]
came off fire super far yeah you're kind
of turning into the
um the new hook guy
i feel like most um projects of
notoriety for the most part recently
have had you on a song yeah that's crazy
think about it like yeah i feel like
you know you've been [ __ ] with raw [ __ ]
with nods like working with nas had to
be crazy yeah that's nuts come on now
that's a legend ain't he a virgo like me
so
were you in the studio with nas yeah
well i had did the first initial session
with hip boy and then when they wanted
me to come back in and add some more to
it knives was up in there with me how
was that it was crazy he was just like
you want some hennessy i don't even
drink hennessy but i did that day he
does that he voices the hennessy
commercials you gotta drink honey with
nuts
you'll be watching nba on tnt and naza's
voice is talking about hennessy that's
crazy that's like not smoking with snoop
exactly
do you smoke i don't smoke would you
smoke with snoop though i wouldn't i'd
be the highest ever
i can't do that i'd be perfect have you
got to get in the studio with snoop
um we didn't work together in the studio
but i definitely pulled up on them at
the compound playing on some music i
feel like smoking with snoop is uh
did you ever smoke snow yeah
yeah was that a good idea or a bad idea
it was a good idea yeah
i would say uh the only person that i
haven't smoked with
that i would love to smoke with is
probably like redman and method man
and
currency would be dope
and like willie nelson what about uh
seth rogen be real is that be real i
haven't smoked with i smoked with whiz
smoke with snoop
um
tons of other guys but yeah i think be
real would be a movie shout out to be
real you know he does those interviews
in the car exactly have you done one of
those
smoke boxes
i would never you don't even have to
smoke you just aren't by the time you
get out your career be over they'll be
like blasts over there tripping
i couldn't i couldn't hang would be real
did you decide not to smoke because of a
bad experience absolutely what happened
i was like 13
in the backyard with my stepbrother and
my cousin
first time ever smoking so they like hit
it hard to hit it harder i'm
like first time smoking
oh i was sitting on the stairs
next thing you know i had an outer body
experience like i really seen my body
like behind me bro
so i was like i'm never doing this again
i went to school high the next day in
junior high school you were still high
the next day still i had to skip school
that day like check out oh you like like
went to the nurse i went to first period
and i was like i was stuck in my chair
like did you ever used to go to the
nurse when you were just bored and be
like man i'm gonna take a nap
nah i wasn't that smart as a kid i would
i wish i was that entombed
yo the nurse knew me i'd be like man
spanish class [ __ ] this i'm going to a
nurse man
i'm gonna go take i'm gonna go get a
napkin real quick
did your parents find out you were high
you know i never told them that story
they don't see this interview
they're gonna be like oh that's why you
just don't we won't rat your cousins out
nah yeah
first time i smoked i was eight yeah
yeah it was uh i just experienced it it
was just it it was painful
i just remember it hurt when i smoked at
first like i hit this the it was a
it was a joint
and i just remember it like burned my
throat i didn't i don't think i got high
i just think it was i was like in pain i
was like this sucks
when you was eight the weed was probably
trash though back then it definitely had
to be trash
and uh
yeah it was um
my parents
in retrospect let me
do a lot of [ __ ] as a kid that i'm like
y'all just let me go over to the
neighbor's crib who was like 17 and like
kick it and i was eight like that's kind
of weird but you know yeah i got high
yeah i feel like when you're a kid you
do way more regular [ __ ] that you never
would even think about doing when you're
an adult i remember walking in certain
neighborhoods that i would never walk in
or just like walking in jet like
i'm a father now
and i think of the [ __ ] my parents would
let me do exactly and i'm like my son
would never be on the bus except that on
the red line
just to go hang out at the mall with his
homies
to steal which was i was doing
so
yeah it's like crazy like because i feel
like back like when we were growing up
parents low-key they had a lot more [ __ ]
to worry about yeah exactly no cameras
it was just
world war ii out there
no there's no uber no nothing you just
got no you got to figure it out you
wanna go hang out with your home he's
gonna figure it out just go get you
figure out these bus routes right did
you ride the bus a lot as a kid
we should take the train for fun the
blue line we should take it from
florence all the way to long beach and
just ride it back great for people
watching yeah it could be also shaky
yeah you get on the wrong [ __ ]
while especially man recently jesus yeah
you see what happened in uh well yeah
there was that shooting in the subway in
new york that [ __ ] was crazy recently
yeah the guy like he uh
dropped a smoke bomb on the train and
like smoked everyone out
and then shot like five people i'm like
[ __ ] that's crazy
16 people got injured i think i did see
that yeah that was wicked
yeah the guy's got like a youtube
channel with a bunch of crazy videos
like it's white's wild and then he was
he vlogged the whole thing no no but he
just like his like manifestos i guess
and then the next day he was just
hanging out at like the deli like
like the whole city wasn't looking for
like it wasn't all over [ __ ] cnn
i'm like bro
it's hot out here for you you might want
to you might want to you know i don't
know bust a bishop or something but
anyway we got to stop the interview real
quick man shout out to our sponsors at
blue chew the good thing about blue chew
not only does it make that dick [ __ ]
you know what i mean
get that thing swinging like it never
swang before
but what i love about blue chew is
it's all online man you know usually
when you want to go and get some of that
uh you know some of that good good some
of that blue juice maybe some viagra
first of all it's got the same exact
active ingredients as viagra and as
cialis but you don't have to go into the
doctor's office to get it all right all
you got to do is go to bluetooth.com you
have an online consultation and then
they discreetly
send it to you and it's also discrete
villain you know what i'm saying
it's crazy let me tell you something
maybe you got a first date you want to
make sure you blow them back out that
dang you know what i'm saying
pop that blue chew it's a chewable form
some people don't like swallowing pills
ladies are gonna love to swallow you
though once you're on that blue chew
i'll tell you that much bud for sure so
what you got to do is go to
bluetooth.com
use the promo code bootleg and you're
going to get a month supply of bluechew
for free all right you're going to thank
me later for this um on this album uh
you just dropped the track list let's
run through some of these features
obviously we talked about zakari who
else is on the project we got aaron ray
on there who's been fired crazy for a
very long time that's my go-to airplane
playlist uh he dropped a project called
platinum fire you know it's crazy
because i feel like he's been around a
long time and somehow has still been
kind of flying under the radar yeah i
don't know what it is but he's fire
underrated as [ __ ] ain't super talented
he produces well
shout out ann ray
uh then i got rick ross on there oh
yeah and i got my boy grandmaster vic
but he's just playing the vienna the
violin your manager
not vic
aka he's grand master vic and victor
ruler how many 80s rappers is he gonna
jack
hey that'll be hard a manager that's a
violin player that'd be crazy that's
crazy yeah [ __ ] all you guys
are like utility knives the whole eagle
crew could do anything you guys are
designing t-shirts setting up all kinds
of [ __ ] you guys have a crazy squad very
efficient squad i would say one of the
more like i feel like
you know
yeah you like everyone has like an i
guess like you said earlier you guys
move with intent and and everything is
very um
strategic on purpose
if that kind of makes sense
rick ross
you guys obviously caught a vibe yeah
this is your second record with him or
is it second second yeah now did this
come from the the same session as the
previous record or is this something i
had that record before i even did his
record okay and i was sitting on it for
a minute and i'm like as soon as i did i
was like damn i'ma get rick ross on here
then his team had reached out for uh
writing camp in miami i landed a hook on
his project i'm like
take that do that
and he hopped on it it was love where
like did you get to um spend any time
with him nah i didn't it was too many
people around we was in the same setting
but it was just a lot it was a lot going
on did you happen to go to any of the
game sessions recently at chalice that
was a lot of people supposed to pull up
i was supposed to pull up it was a very
uh that was a little moment huh like
that weak spin it was like
every time i went it was like a [ __ ]
nightclub that's crazy i was like
this is what my wife thinks studio
sessions are like
like 99 of studio sessions are literally
the opposite
but i'm like if my wife came here she'd
be like oh this is what you'll be doing
at the studio all kinds of ig [ __ ]
and just
it was a lot going on in there yeah
ninja what's your studio vibe like is it
low-key if like is everyone in there
kind of got to have a you know i'll
record at home a lot so i'll be on the
focus right still would you what are we
doing what's your interface at home oh
yeah i got the same [ __ ] bro is it focus
right same simple setup it's a it's a
scarlet though actually scarlett focus
right yeah oh that's the same thing yeah
the red the red one yep
simple setup are you telling me i did
chosen on that
i'm mix chosen it's on the radio i want
everyone to know
you have no [ __ ] excuse
because a focusrite scarlett is 200.
250. yeah
depending on how many inputs you got you
got the two
the four
i got the two
bro so
that's 250 maybe yeah at guitar center
right now what's the mic what's the
at-home mic i got a
i got a road mic
i had this road mic for like six years
you have a road mic yeah do you is it
just straight into the focusrite or do
you have like a cloud lifter or anything
or straight
into the focus
i gotta update my system man but it's
working for me and you're recording you
record you recorded chosen on that mic
yeah
you didn't re-record it or anything nah
yup
this is amazing can we shout out the
rode mic specifically do you know the
model number not the motto it's like in
something i forgot wow
hey man that's impressive thank you bro
because most people they usually have
like one of these you know the shores
with the cloud lifter but that's
impressive yeah we raw dog in it are you
mixing and mastering
um stuff or do you send
like do you have someone to do that for
you i know you could if you wanted to
yeah i mixed uh i also have my boy mix
too his name is lance he did most of the
six tape
but um
it was like half a half for before you
go
when you get into the big studio and you
get on like um
like a sony c800 or something like that
or
u87 do you notice the difference for
sure the vocals just feel way thicker
fuller they pick up every frequency like
it's just a total difference but you're
still like raw dogging it up yeah i'd
rather like be in my bag didn't have a
great sounding well you know that you're
you're well off now things are going
decent you know
you know you could you could do a lit
like you could get just a slight upgrade
you're right
hey i love it though because most people
they got an excuse well you gotta stay
hungry though that's my little way to
stay hungry and people got an excuse for
everything i all man i can't afford this
damn like man listen
what are we talking about go to guitar
center make it work make it happen make
it happen yeah
how um hands on are you still with like
designing the merch
artwork
you know everything i'm sure has to pass
your eye test before it comes out
so yeah that's how the system is set up
now we got a graphic designer on eagle
shout out for sean
but uh for the most part i just give him
my ideas pass on my ideas and let him
rock out then i yes or no the situation
i'm too busy now you're too busy to like
open a photoshop session but i still i
still do it like when i have down time
i'll probably make a cover for a random
single or something that's so different
i'll leave it to him now
that's how's how is the merch doing
because it's fire i love the merch which
is lovely and the actual t-shirt i have
a shirt i bought with the big uh white
eagle the no love lost oh yeah it never
shrinks
it's [ __ ] my go-to like i don't want
to look fat today shirt because it fits
me perfectly like that i could throw
that [ __ ] on and i'm like this [ __ ] you
know i wear xl but sometimes the xl's be
you know fitting me like a [ __ ] like
a schmedium after they get washed and
dry not that shirt come on i got a free
boulet calf commercial right here eagles
go get you one of those shirts man it's
the quality of the cotton all right
quality of the cotton um what's your
favorite uh song on the album my
favorite song it's a song i got called
still on my way
um just really speaking on a journey
enjoying the process
the success um
sharing certain moments with my team
and it's still got that that blast bob
that i know people love me for
when um
people say that uh well you've said it
uh but you know
i've never heard a whack blast record
right
um
are are there were there ever any you
had to delete off the internet from back
in the day because you've been doing
things you've been making a lot of you
now you've been making music a long time
yeah yeah yeah
yeah every i
i think everybody would be lying if they
say they can go delete something but uh
for sure i took something down
a lot of youtube videos
if you can find something
i'ma shoot you you also well whoa
relax
a lot you know it's funny because i'll
be talking to so many random people and
they'll be like oh i got a i got a blast
hook from like three years ago i just
been waiting to put it out and i'll be
like hey yeah good luck with that you
know i'm not coming out buddy how long
how many does that happen often because
you you've been active in the scene for
a very long time like um obviously
on the production side um
you know i'm sure tons of people have
old [ __ ] from you i did so much in the
past i forgot certain things do stuff
come out sometimes like hit the dsps
without you guys even clearing it and
you guys gotta send it right to carl
take him down take that down
carl cherry not carl folks oh okay who's
this my attorney okay your attorney's
the one huh yeah but uh he's an eagle
too so oh oh
you gotta we got an elite squad over
here coming to eagle records eagle
records has the in-house attorney
carl shout out carl fox so that [ __ ]
happens a lot because it's so crazy that
there's no um
if you just have a tunecore account like
you could upload anything right and they
might you know if people aren't paying
attention but distrokit i think they got
a system now to where you got to approve
like if it's a certain name you type in
the yeah distro kid don't play they
don't play
i'm not sure tunecore is as as as
thorough oh yeah but digital kid don't
play sure do you still have stuff on
distrokid i do got a crazy little back
catalog that's you know lovely was the
was the first project um on dish uh no
love loss no well that was on red six
tape six tape was six tape on distrokid
yeah oh that's fire beautiful
you know i feel like
if if everybody could figure out what
they do
with just being able to assign points to
people
like i feel like they're like how how is
district kid the only [ __ ]
distributor that like
allows you to like hey hey sign up for
an account and i'll give you your points
you would think everyone has that but
they really it's like it's like a
distrokid thing it's like yeah it makes
sense
there's probably some other [ __ ] out
there we probably just it's not marketed
to the you know quite possibly yeah
but yeah nah i love i love their uh back
end um
when it comes to like
la
i guess just music in general
i feel like
um seeing you and ty work together was
important because i i know tai
um
another guy who's an absolute alien uh
when it comes to just being talented and
doing everything playing instruments
singing and writing
producing all of it but also
you know for about 10 years straight
the go-to hit uh hook man in in music
you know um
what what's y'all's relationship and did
he kind of give you any game in terms
because you're you're that guy right now
you know what i'm saying man shout out
todd that's big bro i treat him like the
sensei you know i'm saying i'm the
student i like to look at it in that
aspect but
yeah i mean he didn't tell me nothing
personal he just gave me you know a
little motivation to keep going you
doing your [ __ ]
but um
i just be watching everything you know
you ain't got to tell me nothing you
give me you're joking i'm around with it
yeah
how important was um
because i feel like mozzie was pretty
early in terms of just like
being one of the guys who really kind of
co-signed you yeah um
and i feel like you guys have a great uh
he told me you're on his his his debut
interscope album with cmg that's what he
said i said his blast on the album he
said yeah we got we got a couple joints
in the cut so i wouldn't be surprised he
said that you're going to be on all of
his albums for the rest of his career
hey forever in favor forever in my favor
that's what i taught him he's like nah
for the rest of my career i'm having a
blast on every album i was like what
that sounds good you guys should just do
a [ __ ] ep together at this point yeah
nah yeah that don't sound too
far-fetched i always say i wouldn't do
no collab project other than bino and
mozzie those would be the two right so
yeah yo we gotta stop the interview real
quick and tell you about our partners at
odd socks watch this i bet you i got
socks on right [ __ ] now
oh yeah see them bad boys these are what
we call the odd socks basics the ankles
the ankle socks all right go to
oddssocksofficial.com right now
put the website up promo codes bootleg
cab you're going to save 20 off at
checkout they got so many crazy ass
socks we got twizzlers [ __ ] halloween
uh
i mean these are kind of satanic it just
says demon
they were like let's just do a generic
demon sock
i mean this is kind of like uh
i guess like if you were in the 80s in
miami doing cocaine off of a stripper's
[ __ ]
jaws pepsi i mean listen breaking bad
nickelodeon we keep going but what's
most important is odd socks is our
family
look if you support odd socks you
support the bootleg cat podcast so go to
bootleg kev well you can go to
bootleghead.com and just check it out
but you could also go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev and save
20 off at checkout do that [ __ ] right
now all right let's get into the uh
interview that we've already been inside
of but we're gonna get back to it right
now you know what what happened with the
bino project
because
i i i probably know what happened but
for people because you had there was
records on that album
that to me should have been like
worked harder
but i also understand that at the time
you got chosen going crazy you guys are
each on different labels there's
different different labels involved it's
one of those but damn there was some
joints on that album
man i mean i couldn't speak on it you
know he got his like you said he got his
situation i got my situation because who
who was really in charge was it def jam
that was that like that that kind of
handled like working the
the 682 yeah um i think that was through
red bull that [ __ ] project had man
that [ __ ] was a uh
one of them ones as you would say
no pun intended um
after this album comes out what's the
rest of your year looking like i know
that you there's a lot of markets you
didn't hit on tour yeah yeah yeah that's
that's what it is i'm on the road
on the road and on the road bro as soon
as summer hit i might not be back in
adelaide but festival stuff or just like
you're on she's got like three tours
coming up i haven't announced anything
yet but are you going to be going out
with any other bigger artist
quote unquote bigger i might have some
support but for the first for the for
the most part i'm doing my own tour
that's fire yeah
what is the uh have you already locked
in the uh opening opening acts
nah now you're looking though maybe
you're artists you just shout out a
couple people that you know i've been
looking at that's pretty fire okay okay
um
what about
i feel like you're
i mean you you've you know
you have to have a crazy output of
music that we don't hear
because you're so talented in terms like
you're at home recording yourself so i'm
gonna i know that like there's a bunch
of music that's just sitting on a hard
drive but just like
output-wise like where are you trying to
be at the rest of the year are you is it
the album and then are we just going to
kind of
work the album until next year or that's
a good question i think i planted a lot
of seeds that's that's that people
haven't even seen yet this year that's
coming up so
i don't know i think i might have to
take a little step back and let people
appreciate me but
i'm gonna see what this project do if
they if they want more imma listen to
the people uh you and russ uh
me you know we talked about you um you
guys working together
uh
[ __ ] the first time we ever did an
interview which was at the beginning of
the pandemic almost
um
both you guys kind of being in that same
vein of like
uh fully vertical artists i like to call
it yeah um
was there any other records that you
guys we got a couple other joints he'd
just be sending me random [ __ ] sometimes
so he's like another guy who's like he's
like output is crazy like if he like he
puts out a song every week [ __ ]
don't even be paid like they pay
attention but i'm saying like he really
like legitimately
right now is dropping a record it feels
like every week man and they untouchable
though and they're crazy yeah
yeah and then he'll catch like the
handsomer record
that's [ __ ] out of here i'm starting
to pick up on his method
well i think what he did
everyone's going to steal the idea i'm
already noticing people stealing the
idea of what he did with that song
by putting the open verse up on tick
tock
and then
everything you hear that girl that girl
verse on uh
i think it was handsomer caitlyn wraps
the white girl yeah yeah but
but she's she's dope she's coming on the
show uh she's been my wife's been
following her for like a year and a half
on tick tock she's been telling me about
her um
but it's
a lot of artists are going to start to
do that
because
i've already noticed people doing that
like yo
hop on the uh on the duet right on tick
tock and if the winner gets to be on the
actual song
just stuff it just add more life to the
song especially if you're independent
mm-hmm
like run it up run it up yeah
how are you are you pretty um tapped in
with tick-tock it's it's it's a lot
going on on take time right i'm still
trying to learn the whole little system
it's a lot of work bro yeah it is tick
tock is a [ __ ] art form
yeah that's true it is a little keep up
so
you're are you like active on there or
do you just have people posting for you
yeah i'm not active on there i don't
even have people posting we've been
trying to come up with some different
strategies but i like to do [ __ ] that
feel natural it doesn't feel like yeah a
tick tock to me doesn't feel like your
platform yeah exactly you're like real
low-key you know what i'm saying like
yeah no tick-tock is a
it's a lot man even me you know we we
use it but like i'm still frustrated
with that [ __ ] because i'm like bro this
[ __ ] is
the [ __ ] that works on tick tock really
be sometimes just behooves me i'm i'm
very
i think like a platform like this is
good for like with the shorts you do
if you thought i don't take tigers we've
been doing that well not as much as we
should at home cook
[Laughter]
okay cook put my boy on the spot
[Laughter]
hey the big one went crazy yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah so your manager if it
came on our um our podcast we should
have him come in here and clarify what
he meant yeah yeah yo get vic in here
clarify because because he's been
getting yo vic
you got to give them some context stuff
how how do you write off jewelry give us
help us understand that because yeah so
like this right here like well one gold
is an investment it's a mineral true so
it can go up in value and it has
universal trade value true
so in the simplest term
it's like the the government is like if
you're going to invest in an asset
whether it's property or the jury then
you can write that off because you're
basically saying this is a future
investment for me to be able to do
something with it um and as far as
dependent it has my my actual brand on
there i'm owner of the company i'm on
the paperwork so i'm able to say this is
a costume fee or promotional fee for my
company and just be able to write it off
at the end of the year rather than me
spending upfront cash so let's say
technically my my tax bill at the end of
the year was thirty thousand
if i spent fifteen thousand on this
chain i only gotta spend i only gotta
pay fifteen thousand of that back to the
government and the other fifteen
thousand goes down is a write-off
through jewelry
costume experience all that all right so
listen we had a um i asked him if he's
gotten you in trouble with the irs yet
uh
so what the [ __ ] explain your jewelry
because you said that you didn't get to
go all the way in
explaining how to write off jewelry to
the irs
tax season just passed well we're in it
right now
give us the full explanation how does
one write off jewelry okay so i mean so
one i made a mistake last time i call it
a mineral it's a metal so like gold and
silver is a precious metal so like the
same way the irs looks at
property whatever it may be like it's
it's all classifications for everything
right so with anything obviously if you
got a diamond if you got a diamond bust
down
gold chain gold is no longer a value in
the same way right go has to be like a
whole object round they got i mean i
know you always see like coins on the
internet and stuff like that break yeah
bricks right coins just like they
classified as a round or flat metal
pretty much so that's one two it's like
buying or selling
anything of value like an asset like a
house so if you buy they have what's
called a fnv i'm actually pull that up
so you can actually so i can read that
to you but because i don't know that by
heart but fmv is a fair mark fair market
value
and you pretty much subtract the price
of what it was originally purchased by
to the very market value
yeah so and then is that the amount you
could write off so yeah yeah so you take
the amount so let's say if you sell it
or
if you receive it either way right you
take the value of what it currently is
versus the value of what it was bought
for and that difference is what you
pretty much can write off when you buy
but the gold once you put diamonds in it
it doesn't you you're it's it's it did
it it's decreases qualified holes in it
and they don't have to yes so you got to
have like because i know people who
literally like buy like
silver uh these the silver bars yeah the
bars are silver
bars of gold and they'll just put them
in there safe
yeah it's considered an investment by
the irs so like the irs is not like
people be saying like oh like you're
you're you're you're uh your chain right
yeah the actual chain it's just solid
gold that's a solid gold yeah so that's
okay i wrote that off there it is yeah
so but so blast is not funny he's [ __ ]
no not really no no a lot of
you got so then you got other
other ways right so as an artist you
have people that would be like i have
costume fees
right and you have costume fees you can
buy jewelry which are costume fees for a
music video an appearance whatever that
may be and within that costume fee if
you purchase some jewelry with under
that purchase then you can write that
off because obviously you're writing it
off in your taxes saying that that's
just a business expense just part of
your car or a marketing expense because
it's your label exactly so it's
different though because if i write off
gold that's like okay that's like
registered as a piece of property to me
once i appraise it so then when i turn
in my gold if i sell the gold i can get
that tax deduction if i sell it right
him he can't get the sale part you feel
me he can write off the purchase part
but not the reselling of it
yo we got to stop the interview real
quick tell us about uh i'm gonna tell
you about our partners in my bookie man
make sure you go to mybookie.ag right
now
it's gambling season nba playoffs are
about to start what are we doing you can
still get your futures in on the mvp
vote as well you can bet on everything
in my bookie man so look what you got to
do is go to mybookie.com right now
just go to my bookie use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up for a new
account this is important when you sign
up for a new account use that promo code
bootleg and they will give you
a deposit match free money up to a
thousand dollars so if you sign up and
you put 200 bucks in they're gonna give
you another 200 to bet with
thousand they're gonna give you another
thousand to bet with let's go for the
suns all the way just throw all your
money on the phoenix suns
all right and then bet that the warriors
won't make it out of the first [ __ ]
round because yokish is gonna [ __ ]
pound them in their ass
probably great odds on that one
anyway mybookie.ag
mybookie just [ __ ] google the [ __ ] my
bookie use the promo code bootleg and
they will match your deposit free money
free money up to a thousand dollars okay
since we have vic the cpa in the
building
i know that there's a way to write off
your cars at least the depreciation
right i mean we'll so you can
well real quick i'm going to be finished
what's gonna say is and then secondary
isn't there a
certain weight that a car has to be for
you to write off the purchase as like it
being a work vehicle
oh i never heard the weight to be honest
with you someone told me like that's why
everyone buys g-wagons because they're
heavier nah cause you could buy a tesla
for uh for a business car and that [ __ ]
is not nearly as heavy as but i feel
like i i i someone had just explained it
to me a really rich guy
he said that because he had a ferrari
and the license plate uh is his business
name and he has his business name on the
ferrari he said he's only allowed to
write off
the depreciation
whatever that is so he owns the ferrari
he owns the ferrari that's why though
but he was saying if i if i have like if
i bought an escalade it's like after a
certain amount of um he can if he buys
it in his business's name so you can't
write it off as a work vehicle but the
only thing is that you can't
you can't get
you can't write off a finance loan
you can't do that you can only write off
a lease so that's why he can only do
what he said he could do he could only
right now
the depreciation because he owns the
vehicle so now if i went to if i got a
line of credit and i went to
bmw and was like let me get a bmw x6 and
i get it under my line of credit under
eagle then that means that
it's an automatic 100 tax deductible
because it's at least through the
business
and my name is not on it personally the
company's name is on it what's um we got
the the two big dogs the eagle right
here
what is in the future of eagle obviously
the tours the uh he just told me he's
not announcing the tours yet but they're
coming yeah the album's finally here
uh but as a company he just told me
about the new artist i think you had
mentioned him before
um
how many artists are you guys trying to
sign is it gonna be like uh we're gonna
just work one at a time develop you know
are you guys always scouting for talent
like what's what's next for eagle
um i mean honestly i think that we kind
of treating it just the same way we
treating blast's career
it's kind of like as we examine every
step rather than taking that elevator
you know you don't really get to see the
floors when you're on the elevator just
tell you what number you at
when we on these stairs we get to
examine every stair and then we kind of
react based off of what's kind of given
to us you know so right now we're kind
of like in a cause and effect space at
this moment we're not like oh we got to
like pinpoint these 10 artists more so
like okay we're gonna go with the flow
and actually what works and what's
mutually beneficial for the company and
the artist
what about you bless what's like
something you're looking for in an
artist when it comes to like
putting your arm around them you know
what i mean because i feel like not a
lot of people are built like you and
they sure the [ __ ] don't got your work
ethic or you're
just i mean talk about
you know
longevity you've been doing this for so
long you stayed down until it really
worked out a lot of people aren't built
like that so yeah that's definitely what
i look for like multi-talented like jay
million he know how to play every
instrument damn near
and he write produce record himself so
[ __ ] like that is what i'm inspired by
so if i'm not inspired by you then i
wouldn't even want to work with you in
the first place i feel like too it's
important that artists also kind of
self-manage themselves a bit right vic
because it's like you don't want to have
to like hold someone's hand through
every aspect of life 100
i was just telling them yesterday like
um i'm very spoiled in my business
practice at this point because
we don't got to outsource that much and
a lot of stuff that blast needs to take
care of if there is something that pops
up like last minute whether it be a
graphic whether it be screen graphics in
the back for tour
you can kind of look to it not even kind
of he can look to himself to complete it
if it's something that needs to be done
last minute you know what i mean um even
down to recording himself and making
sure that we got fast turnaround coming
back to different artists whether it be
the nazis or the rick ross's people just
coming in tapping in for different
features it's easier just in
communication and efficiency
blast what has been the feature you've
done in the last year and a half or so
that like you kind of had to pinch
yourself and be like this is [ __ ]
crazy i'm on a song with
blank or this person is a fan of mine or
snoop dogg it's new top yeah that's a
legend you know so to work with him was
just insane that's my sister's favorite
artist
so even just being around him is like
that you say that's your sister's
favorite artist this is his favorite
artist well doggy style changed my life
i was that that's the one album that
literally changed my life
sorry yeah doggy style
well i do have a son as well so it
changed my life there as well
yo you guys gotta pick snoops praying
about all this money he's getting
because god damn did you see the uh he
said that that back on death row album
made 21 million dollars
in two days on the metaverse wow but
then he broke down the numbers it made
on spotify and he was like
like nothing he was like it was like you
said 21 million yeah in the metaverse
that's insane oh in the middle so that's
why he took um all of death or his
catalog off of off of dsps you can't go
listen to the chronic right now
damn for real you cannot go listen to
the chronic on uh doggy style nothing
it's a power move though didn't jay-z do
that with title yeah a bit yeah he was
like yo like and he broke down the math
like and then beyonce
because even like i think he did i think
he said he did like eight million
streams or something
on that album like after the super bowl
right like i i don't wanna don't quote
me on that but he i mean we we know what
eight million streams is what is that
that's like four thousand times eight
right like and but on the metaverse we
made 21 million off the same body of
work
it's [ __ ] crazy don't have that
yeah snoop's uh playing we actually were
sitting in a room with stu when he when
he bought that piece of land in the uh
in the metaverse really he was taking
his meeting for that like he was like
hold on i gotta take this crypto meeting
real quick gotta talk about this [ __ ] in
the middle just in the middle was
playing
tapped in too that's the his son is yeah
yeah no um it's crazy because all these
people are spending like hundreds of
thousands millions of dollars to be
snoop's neighbor in that world
i'm still very
like i don't i don't get that [ __ ] at
all i get crypto like coins and like
currencies i get it you know but the nft
or the like buying virtual land [ __ ]
it's above my head at this point but
it's pretty much like
real financial sims it's kind of like
it's like 2k kind of it's like vc like
you're like you got your guy on 2k who's
got like [ __ ] the kobe's on and yeah
and and the custom jersey and but it's
like
it's just not 2k no i feel it it's kind
of wild have you guys done anything in
the uh metaverse or are you guys even
interested
interesting yeah i mean i think we're
always looking alike feels like a
predatory uh environment right now
it's a little while i just think it's no
it's not that many regulations and all
that stuff so i'm saying like i feel
like you guys might [ __ ] around and
hook up with the wrong guys not even
knowing they're the wrong guys
and then end up like tory lane do you
know what i'm saying a lot of smoke in
there you got a lot of smoke in here you
got to clear the smoke see who's real
who's doing good business
darren fox from the kings did you see
that uh
they're like uh he got a charge with
some [ __ ] uh one of those um what do
they call them when they
the pool rug scams on um so he got paid
to
promote like a
was it a nft oh and they took all the
money out and then after he did it yeah
and he's an nba player who just signed a
180 million dollar contract like
bro
yeah
who's your financial advice you're rich
already you won yeah yeah you don't even
got to play in the playoffs every year
you know what i'm saying i think that's
the biggest thing on our side though
right now like we still are
understanding how to manage money
properly i'm not saying that we're doing
crazy stuff but it's just a lot of
business techniques that we're just now
finding out i.e just now getting the
business manager in this past calendar
year um so learning that type of stuff
versus trying to take on new financial
obligation i feel like we gotta master
how we actually in the physical right
now whether that be property consumption
venture capitalism all that type of
stuff and then we can move into the
virtual world last have you um what's
the most ignorant purchase you've made
most ignorant purses
or like outlandish will say i want to
use the word ignorant too crazy um i
bought my sister a car what kind of car
um it was like uh damn you want to know
my sister car yeah why not let me know
what's g well shout out to a jeep yeah i
forget which rapper bought their sister
a car and it was like just like a honda
and everyone was giving him [ __ ] and i
was like well that's a nice car and it's
paid off brand new no [ __ ] what are we
talking about yeah
so you you having like uh
like like splurged on something i ain't
went too crazy maybe after this album
might go a little crazy to celebrate but
yeah sometimes you know even now i'll
buy some [ __ ] and i'll you know i've
been doing a lot better in life the last
four or five years
but i just bought a house and that [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
yeah that [ __ ] like
definitely wiped me out kind of nice you
know yeah so for about two or three days
i had that like feeling remember we were
young
and you go [ __ ] off like all the money
you saved on like a pair of kicks or
something and then you get home from the
mall and you'll be like [ __ ] yeah i know
that feeling that's the first time in a
long time i had that feeling was buying
this [ __ ] house in burbank
but i got a house
um
so the album is officially out go run
the album up um hopefully we're going to
be uh obviously new merch is going to be
coming out tour is going to be coming
when's uh your guys's first art like
when's the artist you've been telling us
about when's he dropping his
we cooking we ain't got no set date
right now okay just cooking up yeah uh
i'm assuming there's a lot more blast
hooks coming
absolutely and i got a record on kalani
album drop in next week too shout out to
kailani
was that uh in person session or no i
wasn't it wasn't but we uh linked up at
the video shoot when we shot the video
she's a vibe
super vibe anybody else that you're
working with that oh you know maybe some
sessions you've been in recently we
might you know i have to find out it's
gonna be a crazy the way he's looking up
right now
it's gonna be a crazy year you have no
idea this weekend post malone joint
album
[Laughter]
the biggest [ __ ] ever that's funny oh
man well there it is man i appreciate
you pulling up glass always um the album
is out go run it up
you could choose to listen to this guy's
financial advice
hey google it google is your friend
exactly victor ruler shot to eagle man
perfect